(music)
The book grew out of my own personal experiences.
I went through a long period of chronic stress, and I myself came down with arthritis.
I went with neighbors to the Greek island of Crete, and that was a turning point in my healing.
(music)
We know now not only that stress can make you sick, but how stress can make you sick.
And also the opposite: how relaxing, how finding a place of peace, can help you heal.
And that's really what the book is about. It's about taking that science that proves these connections,
and putting it into the space around us. I
knew of a groundbreaking study by environmental
psychologist Roger Ulrich, who had published a paper in the journal Science in 1984 showing
that patients who were recovering from gall
bladder surgery, whose beds were beside windows
with views of trees, views of nature, healed
on the average a day faster, and needed less
pain medication, than patients in the same
room who had a view of a brick wall.
And that study really impressed me, and it certainly impressed the scientific community, and suggested
there is something about what you see, or
what you hear, or what you smell, or what
is it about those views that could help speed healing.
(music)
So this is one of my healing places, I come here when I'm stressed and when I need a place to just sit
and meditate and reflect. It's the Bishop's Garden of the National Cathedral. It's lots of green.
In the summer there's beautiful roses, and the smell, and you can sit and look at the beautiful
view of downtown Washington, and for me it's a place where I come to heal.
Feeling better because you believe in something in medical terms is called "the placebo effect,"
and unfortunately that carries with it a lot of
baggage, you say "oh, you know, it's just the placebo effect."
Well the placebo effect is a very powerful
effect. It probably contributes to about thirty
percent or more of any cure. And what it is
is it's the brain's own healing processes.
And it's pretty clear that place can trigger
the brain's own healing processes.
Health care design architects have really embraced this, and, ultimately, the practical application--
for example for health care--is to design hospitals, or healing places, that will help people to
heal, rather than to be stressful and harm
us. Because if something as simple as a window,
and the view outside of it, can help a patient heal, think how much better patients would
be in hospitals if we on purpose incorporated all the elements of design that can help us heal.
(music)
In the course of doing the research
for this book, I visited a lot of healing
places--the labyrinth at Chartres, Boulder,
Colorado, and the scientists who work out of there.
Marburg, Germany, with its castle on the hill, that is so reminiscent of Disneyland's castles.
And in fact I describe the Disney theme parks.  There are many healing places around the world.
It's only up to us to find our own healing
place. And it can be as small as your favorite
chair in the living room, in front of the
fireplace, or it can be as large as a view
from a mountaintop. There is a turning point
in every illness, where you go from the dark
side to the light, and how do we get there?
How do we get to that turning point, and can
the place around you help you get there? And,
ultimately, the answer is yes.